Xi Jinping spent the past few years
reigning in China's Tech Giants now as
he faces a backlash over his handling of
the covid-19 pandemic the Chinese
president is discovering he might need
them
[Music]
in mid-2020 Alibaba and tencent seemed
on track to become trillion dollar
companies then everything changed
concerned about their Rising influence
she targeted the e-commerce giant
Alibaba for perceived monopolistic
conduct and tencent which owns the super
app WeChat for its tight grip on music
streaming rights other Tech firms came
into the firing line too that appears to
be changing judging by an economic
planning meeting in December during that
meeting he signaled strong support for
the tech sector that's because after
cover zero policies the Chinese economy
is really tanking so right now he needs
a new way to fire up the economy again
that's why he looked at Tech because
Tech has been the Chinese growth engine
for the past decade that doesn't mean
it's returned to business as usual for
China's Tech Giants but life might start
to get just a little bit easier
foreign